اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
في اسرائيل الشرطه تتاهب وفوضى تهدد الامن
ولجنه الدستور تصادق على التعديلات
القضائيه
يبحث التعليق التعديلات القضائيه
بعد الجامعات نقابه الاطباء تعلن اضرابا
شاملا في النظام الصحي
على وقع التحذيرات الاوروبيه بعد نشوي
الاسلحه النوويه موسكو لا تستبعد اي
خيارات لرد على العقوبات الغربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اسرائيل يتصاعد
الوضع السياسي والامني على خلفيه ازمه
التعديلات القضائيه وسط استنفار الامني
وتاهب للشرطه والجيش فيما تتسع الاضرابات
لتشمل قطاع الصحه والطيران بعد اضراب شامل
للجامعات حيث اعلنت قبل قليل الهيئه
المطارات الاسرائيليه وقف اقلاع الطائرات
بمطار بن غوريون واما التصعيد والفوضى
اعلن قذف الاحتجاج تمسكهم بالغاء
التعديلات القضائيه وليس مجرد تعليقها حيث
اتجه رئيس الوزراء بن امين في الساعه
الاخيره لبحث التعليق التعديلات وفي خضم
ما تشده اسرائيل من احداث وتطورات متسارعه
ليوقف التعديلات القضائيه فورا الاغلبيه
بين وزراء بين وزراء حزب العكود
الاسرائيلي ايضا تؤيد وقف التعديلات
القضائيه بحسب مراسل العربيه وفي الاثناء
مشاهدينا اعلنت قناه 12 الاسرائيليه ان
لجنه الدستور بالكنيسه الاسرائيلي صادقت
على التعديلات القضائيه بالقراءتين
الثانيه وال ثالثه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هجم زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل الا بهت
حكومه نتنياهو مؤكدا في مؤتمر من داخل
الكنيست على انها فقدت بوصلتها واصبحت
خطرا على اسرائيل وامنها واضاف ان حكومه
نتنياهو طردت وزير الدفاع لانه قال
الحقيقه ودع قيادات حزب الايكود الى
الوقوف في وجه ما وصفه بجنون الحكومه
مشاهدينا من القدس ينضم الينا مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد
وبدايه زياد هل تاكدت معلومات حول مصير
خطاب نتنياهو بشان هذه الازمه
كما كان متوقعا بسبب الصعوبات الجمه التي
تعترضه داخل التوليف الحاكم داخل الاحزاب
الحاكمه هو يرجى هذا الموضوع ربما خلال
نصف ساعه المقبله ولكن ليس اكيدا
سيحاول ان يرجى هذا الامر حتى يتيقن تماما
من ان هذا هذه الكلمه التي سيعلن كما قلنا
فيها وقف او تعليق التشريعات
والدخول في حوار مع معارضي هذه التشريعات
ان يتيقن بان ذلك لن عمليا يفكك ائتلافه
وان لا يكون تهديد الوزير بن جبير مثلا
وتهديدا جديا باسقاط الحكومه والائتلاف في
حال اوقف نتنياهو التشريعات لهذا هو ياخذ
وقته في هذا المجال وان كان الاعتقاد
السائد بان تهديدات بين كبير قد لا تكون
مع رصيد حقيقي لسبب انه يدرك بان انتخابات
جديده الان ليست في صالح الاحزاب اليمينيه
اقله وفق استطلاعات الراي المتكرره في
اسرائيل في الشهرين الاخيرين طيب بالنسبه
اذا كانت هناك تسريبات ام لا يعني ما هو
الارجح هل سيتم التاجيل ام سيتم الغاء
تماما وما هو رد الشارع المتوقع
طبعا استبق المحتجون قاده المحتجين
استبقوا كلمه نتنياهو بالاعلان مسبقا
بانهم بانهم لن يكتفوا باعلان تعليق او
وقف التشريعات وانما يريدون اسقاطها بمعنى
يريدون من نتنياهو مثلا ان يطرح هذا
القانون للتصويت اليوم في الكنيست وان
يسقطه بنفسه ان يقوم الائتلاف والمعارضه
معا باسقاط هذا القانون ودفن هذه الخطه
عمليا لا ارى نتنياهو سيوافق على امر كهذا
لكنه قد يعلن وقف او تجميد
التشريعات ربما اذا اعلن مثلا الى حين
التوافق على صيغه هذا قد يكون نوعا ما
كافيا لانه لن يتم التوافق قريبا على صيغك
هذه وهذا ياخذ منحه وقف تام لهذه الخطه
بهذا المعنى الامور تبدو
طبعا نتنياهو سيحاول الدفاع عن نفسه ويقول
بان خطه الاصلاح هي كانت لا تهدف الى
تقويض الديمقراطيه وما الى ذلك وكان لها
مكان وستتم في مرحله ما وسيدخل في حوار مع
الاخرين لكنه بات في ورطه حقيقيه عمليا
بدا في الاونه الاخيره معزولا ومسلوقا عن
الواقع في اسرائيل اعتقد بانه بسبب وجود
اغلبيه من 64 نائبا يستطيع ان يغير ما
يشاء في النظام السياسي والقضائي في
اسرائيل اتضح له من خلال الشارع بان ذلك
يبدو صعبا جدا وعمليا الشارع فرض رغبته
على الحكومه وعلى نتانياهو اذا ما يقص كنت
معنا مدير مكتبه العربيه في فلسطين زياد
حلبي شكرا معك في متابعه دائما لهذه
التطورات
ووصل التوتر الامني والسياسي يخطط
المحتجون الاسرائيليون الى محاصره مقر
الكنيست في القدس الغربي بعد ظهر اليوم
الاثنين وفقا لمراسل العربيه وسط توقعات
باعلان سكرتير النقابات المهنيه ورؤساء
البلديات اضرابا عاما من شانه ان يشل
البلاد هذا وكان اسرائيل عاشت ليله ساخنه
على الاحتجاجات التي اندلعت بعد اقاله
نتنياهو لوزير الدفاع حيث خرج الالاف من
الاسرائيليين في مظاهرات ضد ائتلاف
نتنياهو الحكومي
حث الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق حكومه نتنياهو
على وقف مشروع تعديلات القضاء المؤثي
للجدل وذلك غداه اقاله رئيس الوزراء
لوزير دفاعه بعد ان طالب الاخير بتاجيل
التعديلات القضائيه لمده شهر ودع هيرسوكا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه عبر حسابه على تويتر
الى وقف العمليه التشريعيه على الفور من
اجل وحده شعب اسرائيل وتحاملا للمسؤوليه
على حد تعبيره هذا وانضم قائد شرطه تل
ابيب الى التظاهرات ضد حكومه بنيامن
نتنياهو بعد ان اصدر وزير الامن القومي
اثمار بنجفير قرارا منذ قرابه اسبوعين
باقالته عازيا السبب الى تساهله مع
المتظاهرين نتابعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
فضيحه جديده في الجيش الاوكراني فبعد
الفساد متطوعون بلا خبره
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد تاكد مدير
اداره التعاون الاقتصادي بوزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه على ان بلاده لا تستبعد اي خيارات
لرد على العقوبات الغربيه لكنها تتجنب
اتخاذ تدابير تعسفيه جاءت تصريحاته بعد
اعلان منسق السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبيل عن استعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي
لفرض عقوبات جديده اذا وافقت بيلاروسيا
على نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه روسيه على
اراضيه على اراضيها عفوا قضيه الهجوم على
خط انابيب تعود الى الواجهه مجددا حيث
سيعقد مجلس الامن مساء اليوم جلسه بطلب من
روسيا للتصويت على مشروع قرار روسي يتعلق
بتفجيرات خطوط الذي ادى الى وقوع اضرار
جسيمه بهذه الانابيب في بحر البلطيق مشروع
القرار الروسي يطلب من الامين العام
انطوني غوتيريش تشكيله لجنه تحقيق دوليه
مستقله للنظر في هذه التفجيرات
قال مندوب موسكو الدائم لدى المنظمات
الدوريه في فيينا ميخائيل ان بلاده ستعتزم
دعوه المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
بالطاقه الذريه رفع الجروسسي لزياره موسكو
في المستقبل القريب ونفى ان تكون هذه
الزياره الاسبوع المقبل كما اعلن الكرسي
سابقا وكان جروستي قد اعلن خلال عطله
نهايه الاسبوع انه سيزور محطه النوويه
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في اوكرانيا
لتقييم الوضع الخطير هناك وللمطالبه ايضا
باقامه منطقه امنيه حولها
استمر منذ بدايه فبراير الماضي في
بريطانيا لاستخدام دبابات تشالنجر اثنين
التي تعهدت المملكه المتحده بنقلها الى
كييف الجدير بالذكر المشاهدين انه في
الرابع عشر في الرابعه عشر من يناير
الماضي كانت المملكه المتحده كانت اول
دوله غربيه تعلن انها ستنقل اربع عشره
دبابه قتال رئيسي من طراد
ذاته اعلن وزير الدفاع البريطاني ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ستتلقى
الدبابات قبل بدايه الصيف لكن وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه لم تذكر تواريخ دقيقه
لهذا الامر
كشف المتحدث باسم حرس الحدود الاوكراني عن
تخلص اعداد الجنود الروسي بيلاروسيا الى
4000 جندي وقال اندريد منشكو قال ان
المعلومات المتوفره تشير الى ان اعداد
الجنود الروس داخل بيلاروسيا وعلى حدود
اوكرانيا كانت تقدر بعشره الاف جندي لكنها
اليوم تراجع الى نحو اربعه الاف جندي
بعد فوضى ومشاجرات وصخب استكمل مجلس
النواب العراقيه تصويت على التعديل الثالث
لقانون الانتخابات في جلسه حضرها 189
نائبا التعديلات في قانون انتخابات تشكل
عوده الى قانون الذي كان مرعيا قبل
تظاهرات اكتوبر عام 2019 وهو ما اثار غضب
الاحزاب المستقله والصغيره التي ترى انه
يخدم مصالح الاحزاب الكبيره وبذلك ستجرى
الانتخابات البرلمانيه وانتخابات مجالس
المحافظات المتوقعه في نوفمبر المقبل على
اساس القانون المعدل
[موسيقى]
يدخل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالعوده لمتابعه تطورات
المتسارعه في اسرائيل
عبر الهاتف المحلل السياسي
حلبي في نهايه المقابله مع حينما اتحدث عن
ان نتنياهو بدا في ورطه وانه بدا ايضا
معزونا عن الواقع هل ترى ان نتنياهو اخطا
في حساباته فيما يتعلق بملف التعديلات
القضائيه
نعم اعتقد ان النت له يحاول الان الخروج
من هذه الورطه حيث في هذه الساعه
يجتمع
اجتماعا موسعا للرسائل
في ضوء اعتزامه الاعلان عن تجميد مراحل
التشريع
الاحزاب المتدينه تؤيده في هذا الاجراء
نظرا لتداعيات السلبيه التي نجمت عن
الاجراءات في حين ان الاحزاب اليمينيه
المتطرفه
بنيفيرش يعرضون مثل هذا القرار خشيه من
التداعيات السلبيه لمكان وايضا تلبيه
للدعوه او
[موسيقى]
للوعود الذي قطعوها لجمهورنا ناخدين
بالاستمرار للاصلاح القضائي
امام الحيره كيف سيحافظ على الائتلاف
الحكومي الراهن بدون احداث انشقاق وما هو
البديل وهذا من جهه من جهه ثانيه هناك
نداء من قبل المعارضه وايضا من داخل صفوف
الليكود باعاده القرار بعزل وزير الدفاع
واعادته الى منصبه زد على ذلك التطور
الاخير هو القرار نقابه العمال العامه
بالاعلان عن الاضراب العام وشلل جميع
المرافق الاقتصاديه
وكل هذه المعطيات التي اشرت اليها من
لتتوقع ان نسمعه من نتنياهو في خطابه
المتوقع بعد ربما نصف ساعه من الان
تراجع عن القرار الاصل وهو الاستمرار في
المضاعف التشريه انه سيدعو الى الدخول الى
المفاوضات لايجاد مخرجا من الازمه ببواسطه
القضائيه سيد شلومو
اعتقد انه يطلب
التجميد مؤقت للمراحل التشريع خاصه عندما
على ابواب الاعياد اليهوديه والعياده
القوميه ونهايه الدوره الشتويه للكنيست في
النهايه هذا الاسبوع لذلك هو يطلب متسع من
الوقت من الجميع لتقييم الاوضاع
والوصول الى حلول وسط الجميع وتهدئه
الاوضاع خاصه الاوضاع في الشارع
الاسرائيلي بعد القرار اقاله وزير الدفاع
هل بالامكان ان نتنبا بماهيه هذه حلول
الوسط التي يمكن ان ترضي جميع الاطراف
هذا يتوقف على الاطراف وعلى مواقف الاطراف
المعارضه تطالب بانه ينتحد كليا من مشروع
الاصلاح والبدء من جديد لايجاد كراسه
مشتركه اعتقد بانه بعد ان بلغت مراحل
التشريع هذه المرحله الهامه من التقدم
اعتقد بانه سيكون من الصعب عليه التجاوب
معها ولكن من جهه ثانيه علي هناك تهديد
بالانشقاق داخله لدلا
ف الحكم تهديد داخل حزب الليكود
باستقاله وزير العدل الذي هو الذي يقود
مشاريع القوانين الاصلاح وهذا قد يحدث
ازمه داخليه داخل الحزمه اللي يكون ليس
فقط داخل الائتلاف الحكومي اعتقد بان من
السابق لاوانه التنبؤ امام نتنياهو مشاكل
جمه سياسيه داخليه سياسيه خارجيه وايضا
الوضع الامني الاستراتيجي الذي تواجه
اسرائيل من جراء التهديدات الايرانيه
والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه المؤكده بان
ايران تقف وراء المشاعي لتوحيد جميع
الجبهات اسرائيل ماذا عن قوى اليسار الى
اي مدى ترى انها قد استفادت من هذه الازمه
بعد المجرات التي شاداها انه هناك من
المستفيد بل هناك ايضا ادراك الجميع سواء
اليسار واليمين وسائر
التيارات المختلفه بان وصلت
وصل الوضع الى
وضع لا يطاق وانه يجب على الجميع محاسبه
النفس
للاج اللي مخرج متفقين عليه زائد في حال
[موسيقى]
اجتماع احد الاسرار بان النتائج ابناء
الليل الماضيه حتى
لا نشهده من شلل في جميع المرافق
الاقتصاديه في اسرائيل سيكون
هو هو
الخط المسيطر وهو الذي سيؤدي الى خروج من
هذه الازمه اعتقد بان الجميع عليهم النزول
من الشجره التي صعدوا اليها منذ اربعه
اشهر واعتقد باننا في المراحل الاخيره من
اقتناء الجميع بان هناك سلم للنزول
شكرا لك كنت معنا من القدسال عبر الهاتف
المحلل السياسي
مشاهدينا ينضم الى النظير المجلي المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك سيد نظير معنا في هذه
النشره وبدايه وفق المعطيات الحاليه هل
ترى ان الازمه في طريقها الى الحل ام الى
مزيد من التعقيد والمواجهه
مرحبا بكم المشاهدين المشاهدات لا القضيه
لا اعتقد انها ستحل بهذه السرعه وهذه
السهوله القضيه التي يطرحنا نتنياهو انه
يريد ان يوقف المد الغير في الطبيعي وغير
المسلوق في تاريخ الجرائد ولكن
يتنازل وحلفاؤه عن هذه الخطه
والحمله الاحتجاز
تتنازل عن احداث تغييرات يعني نحن نتحدث
الان ليس فقط
انقلاب
يمين الاسرائيلي لانما نتحدث عن انقلاب عن
الانقلاب ورغبه ومطالبات يعني يكون هناك
دستور في اسرائيل يمنع في المستقبل ايه
الحكومه عام القيام بهذه الخط
وفي الاسبوع القادم لدينا عدد من الجلسات
المحكمه العليا التي ستكون مضطره للطباء
للبحث في القوانين التي تمها حتى الان قسم
من القوانين قدمت دعاوى ضد اليهود وعليه
ان ينزل امام المحكمه هو او مندوبون عنه
اللي يطرحوا موقفهم والمحكمه من الممكن ان
تصاعد اكثر لانها لن تستطيع ان تقبل هذه
القوانين باعتبار القوانين
وعن هذه القوانين اذا قررت على المحكمه
رفضها ورفض نتنياهو قرار المحكمه تصبح
هناك اغلب السوريه لذلك نحن من الممكن ان
يكون الان حل لقضيه الاضراب العام ولكن
ليس للقضيه الجوهريه المرتبطه بالانقلاب
على
انظمه الحكم في اسرائيل وفيما يتعلق
بارشاد دستور كما تفضل سيد مجله هل ترى ان
ذلك الخيار سيكون مقبولا من جميع الاطراف
السياسيين خاصه حزب الليكود بزعامه هل
سيقبل ان يكون لي باسرائيل د ستور يقيده
في هذه المرحله
يشهد صراع داخليا حاده جدا للقياده الايام
حيث ان هنالك فئه ليست قليلات تؤيد هذا
التوجه ولكنها لا تجرؤ على الخروج ضد
نتنياهو خصوصا وان نتنياهو قال جلل بسبب
قضيه هذه يعني مجرد انه تجرا واتخذ موقفا
مهنيا مربوطا بما قاله له رسائل
عنهم
و ياتي بقالته بهذا الشكل الان تقول
يخافون ولكن بدات تص
نع جديده في داخل الكهود لا تستنى بعيدا
لتاييد الدستور الدستور عمليه كبيره
ومعقده وتحتاج الى استفتاء شعبي فيما بعد
ولكن يتحدثون عن ضروره اجراء التغييرات
يريدون من ان يتخذ قرارات اكثر عمقا من
تاجيل البحث هذه القوانين لان الليكود بدا
يخسر قاعدته الجماهيريه نتيجه عندما نتحدث
اليوم مثلا عن اغلاق مطار بنك من اغلق
مطار بن غريون هي نقابه المحليه هناك
ورئيسها من الكويت وظهر وقال ان انا من
الكويت سابقى في الكويت ولكني اخجل لانني
ولهذا يجب ان نعمل الاضراب فيوجد
من الممكن ان يؤدي الى
الخلافات
تساعد بعض الشيء الحمله الاحتجاج وحمله
الاحتجاج مستمره على القيادات هناك ليست
قياده حزبيه ليس لبيد ليس جنس من يقود هذا
الاهتزازات هي حمله احتياجات مستمره كما
تفضلت ولكن السؤال هنا لماذا لا يمضى الى
هذه الخطوه من نتنياهو هي خطوه بحسب
التسريبات تاجيل هذه التعديلات القضائيه
لماذا لا ينظر اليها كاستجابه اوليه
والبناء عليها مستقبل لتحقيق مزيد من
المكاسب ام ان الازمه في تقديرك هيباتت
ازمه الثقه
توجد خطه للانقلاب على انظمه الحكم في
اسرائيل وليس فقط على جهاز ليست فقط
اصلاحات قضائيه انما هناك محاوله لزعزعت
اركان الاسس الاركان والاسس التي تقوم
عليها اسرائيل والتي يعتبرونها هي اساسا
الديمقراطيه وبالمقابل يريدون ان يضعوا
اسس جديده
واخذ هنا دستور الذي يمنع امكانيه ان تقوم
بمثل هذه الخطوات في ايه حكومه في
المستقبل يعني الموضوع
لدرجه انه لا يعني لا القضايا
الميكانيكيه ان تؤجل البحث اسبوعا او
اسبوعين قد يحدث هذا الامر ولكن هذا لن
يوقف حمله الاحتجاج شكرا لك من الناصره
كنت معنا نظير مجلي المحلل السياسي تحياتي
نشاطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
في المانيا الاضرابات تشل حركه النقل
وتؤثر على نحو نصف مليون مسافر
استنفار في اسرائيل الشرطه تتاهب وفوضى
تهدد الامن ولجنه الدستور تصادق على
التعديلات القضائيه
يبحث تعليق التعديلات القضائيه وقاده
الاحتجاج يتم السكون بالغائها وبنكفير
يحذر من التراجع
الاضرابات تهدد بشل اسرائيل بعد الجامعات
نقابه الاطباء تعلن اضرابا شاملا في
النظام الصحي
على وقع التحذيرات الاوروبيه بعد نشر
الاسلحه النوويه موسكو لا تستبعد اي
خيارات للرد على العقوبات الغربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد تشهد المانيا
اكبر اضراب منذ عقود حيث توقف اليوم العمل
في شبكه المواصلات الالمانيه بشكل شبه
كامل بسبب الاضراب الذي قرر تنفيذه اكبر
نقابتي بل قررت اكبر نقابه عمان في البلاد
للمطالبه بتحسين ظروف العمل وزياده الاجر
وقد اعلن موظفون وعمال في المطار والموانئ
وشبكه الانفاق والسكك الحديديه الاضراب عن
العمل وتنظيم مظاهرات ضخمه في مختلف انحاء
البلاد وياتي هذا الاضراب ضمن موجه
اضرابات شهدتها المانيا اخيرا بدات
بمسيرات صغيره ومتفرقه بين الحين والاخر
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في عدد من قطاعات
الخدمه العامه للمطالبه بزياده في الاجور
تعوض الارتفاع غير المسبوق في معدلات
التضخم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من برلين تنضموا الينا ممارسه
العربيه رغد ذبحناهم اهلا بك راغده وبدايه
رغده كيف بدات المدن الالمانيه وقطاعاتها
الاقتصاديه والحيويه على وقع هذا الاضطراب
صباح الخير اهلا بك يا نداني ابدا في
البدايه لاقول يعني اننا نقف في المحطه
الرئيسيه محطه القطارات الرئيسيه في برلين
من هذه المحطه تنطلق عاده قطارات ليس فقط
الى مختلف المدن الالمانيه ولكن ايضا الى
مدن خارج المانيا مدن قريبه في اوروبا
يعني
هذه المحطه اليوم هي يعني بالفعل مقفله
يمكن ان نلاحظ لوحه يعني سندوب الكاميرا
لكي نلاحظ لوحه
الاعلانات الرئيسيه هنا في المحطه هي ليست
فقط يعني لا تقول بان القطارات ملغيه
ولكنها مطفئه تماما خلفي يعني يتحولت الى
لوحه سوداء ليس عليها ايه اعلانات لاي
قطرات اليوم تغادر هذه المحطه يعني
باستثناء المترو الانفاق الذي ايضا يعني
الذي محطه هنا في هذه يعني في محطه
القطارات الرئيسيه ليس هناك بالفعل ايه
قطارات تتحرك من هنا يعني شركه القطارات
الرئيسيه قالت بان هناك بعض الباصات التي
وضعت في الخدمه كي لا يكون هناك شلل كامل
في حركه المسافرين ولكن يعني هناك غياب
تقريبا شبه كامل للمسافرين من هنا وهذا
يعني هذه الصوره التي نشاهدها هنا هي ربما
افضل من مدن اخرى كثيره في المانيا لانه
برلين ربما اقل تاثرا من غيرها لانه
المطار اصلا ما زال يعني هو يعمل مطار
برلين هو واحد من المطارات القليله التي
ما زالت يعني مفتوحه اليوم امام حركه
المسافرين ولكن معظم المطارات الالمانيه
الكبرى من ميونخ وفرانك وغيرها من
المطارات هامبرغ كلها يعني حركه المسافرين
توقفت فيها بشكل كلي ولكن يعني في المقابل
هناك اليوم ايضا تجري جوله مفاوضات جديده
بين نقابات العمال او نقابتين العمال هذا
التي يعني اعلنت هذه الحركه حركه الاضراب
وبين شركات القطارات
واليوم يعني ربما يتم التوصل لاتفاق وهناك
امل لدى محطه القطارات هنا او لدى شركات
القطارات بان يتم ربما معاوده العمل بعض
الظهر ويعني التخفيف من هذه الحركه
المشلوله بشكل كبير في مختلف ولايه
الالمانيه
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
تحياتي رغده
انتهى الاجتماع الامني الذي عقد في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس وضم قيادات عسكريه
وامنيه بارزه من الشرق من الشرق والغرب
بحضور المبعوث الامي عبد الله وخلص اللقاء
الى دعم جهود المصالحه الوطنيه وتوحيد
المؤسسات العسكريه بحسب ما افاد مراسل
العربيه كما اتفق الفرقاء على دعم اجراءات
اجراء الانتخابات خلال العام الجاري
والتعهد بحمايتها والعمل ايضا على توحيد
المؤسسات التنفيذيه وجاري الاتفاق على
اطلاق سراح كافه الاسرى من الطرفين باشراف
لجنه مشتركه والتاكيد على وقف اطلاق النار
بين الاطراف وتغيب لغه الحوار لحلحله
المشاكل والى اثيوبيا مشاهدينا وبين
العوده الى الصور الملتقطه عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه المنتشره المنتشره مؤخرا والتي
اظهرت استعدادات اثيوبيا للملء الرابع لسد
النهضه حيث اوضحت فتح البوابه الغربيه
للسد وترك البوابه الشرقيه لتصريف حوالي
50 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
هذا هو اكد خبره ان ادار تنو ان اضرارا
تتنوع بين المائي والسياسيه فضلا عن
البيئيه ستلحق بمصر والسودان في حال اصرت
اثيوبيا على الملء الرابع دون تنسيق هذا
وكانت اثيوبيا اعلنت قبل ايام انها انتهت
من بناء تسعين في المئه من السد وذلك
مع دولته مصر والسودان بسبب عدم التوافق
على الملء والتشغيل واتخاذ اديس ابابا
قرارا احاديا منفردا بالتصرف دون مشوره او
تنسيق مع الدولتين
في لبنان وبعد الجدل الكبير المتعلق
بالتوقيتين الشتوي والصيفي دعا رئيس
الحكومه اللبنانيه نجيب ميقات مجلس
الوزراء الى عقد جلسه
ظهر اليوم ووجهت الامانه العامه لمجلس
الوزراء دعوه الى الوزراء لحضور جلسه في
السراي الكبير لمناقشه قرار التعديل
التوقيت بعد ان قرر رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الموافقه الاستثنائيا على تاجيل تطبيق
قرار مجلس الوزراء المتعلق بتعديل التوقيت
الى كوريا الشماليه حيث اختبارات الصواريخ
مستمره اخرها اعلان كوريا الجنوبيه اطلاق
جارتها الشماليه صاروخين بارسيين قصيري
المدى باتجاه بحر اليابان وهما الاحدث في
سلسله الاختبارات خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
حسبما اعلن جيش الكوري الجنوبي وقالت هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الكوريه الجنوبيه ان
الامر يعد استفزازا خطيرا يمس بسلام
المجتمع الدولي وشبه الجزيره الكوريه
واستقارهما مؤكدا بل مؤكده ان الجيش شدد
عمليات المراقبه لمواجهه عمليات اطلاق
جديده والحفاظ على جهزيته الدفاعيه
مشاهدينا يوجد دوله سوريا
واربعه مغلقه لكن باب العمود اكبرهم
واكثرهم شهره ويعد الباب الرئيسي بل يعد
الباب الرئيسي المؤدي لمسجد الاقصى يتزين
في شهر رمضان بالفوانيس والاضواء ويتوافد
مئات الالاف من المسلمين منه واليه حيث
يعتبر الفلسطينيون ارثا وطنيا
ومتنفسا لهم
[موسيقى]
هنا باب العمود اضخم البوابات الرئيسيه
للبلده القديمه بالقدس بارتفاع يبلغ
ثمانيه امتار اكثرهم ثراء من حيث الزخارف
ويعود اسمه الى الفتره الرومانيه حيث تم
وضع عمود من الرخام الاسود يصل ارتفاعه
ضعف ارتفاع الباب في الساحه الداخليه وتم
استخدام العمود كاداه لقياس بعد مسافات
الدول والمدن عن مدينه القدس وللباب اسم
اخر اقل تداولا هو باب دمشق لانه كان
الباب الذي تخرج منه القوافل التجاريه الى
دمشق
وللباب اجواء رمضانيه خاصه حيث يتزين
بالاضواء والفوانيس ويتوافد عشرات الالاف
من المسلمين للدخول من هذا الباب وصولا
للمسجد الاقصى ويجلس المئات على درجات باب
العمود لتناول الحلويات بعض الافطار من
البسطات او حتى لتناول وجبه السحور قبل
الفجر لا نقل غاصي من القدس العربيه
ضجه كبيره وثيره مع بدء عرض مسلسل الفلوجه
في تونس ومطالبات بايقاف العمل ابرزها
كانت من وزاره التربيه والتعليم بمصالحها
القانونيه الوزاره رفعت دعوه تطالب باعاده
مراجعه العمل وحذف مشاهد اعتبرتها مسيئه
للمؤسسه العموميه وهي المربين والتلاميذ
على حد سواء تقرير الدراهم الرمضاني
اليومي مع سهى الوال وايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره بدات مع بدء عرض مسلسل
الفلوجه في تونس ومطالبات بايقاف العمل
ابرزها كانت من وزاره التربيه بمصالح
القانونيه واللي رفعت دعوه تطالب بمراجعه
العمل وحذف مشاهد اعتبرتها مسيئه للمؤسسات
العموميه وللمربين والتلاميذ على حد
السواء كل صدق ما كملتوش ما كملتوش على
خاطر انا حسيتو المسلسل هذايا ماهوش
مع كل من
طالب بدعوه الى ايقاف هذا المسلسل لانه
يسيئ منه ويسيء من شبيبتنا ومن تلاميذه
النوب والمؤسسه التربويه خاصه هو المسلسل
فيه الواقع التونسي
وفي زاده قلت احترام على خاطر عبيد في
رمضان تجيب حاجات محترمه بدها تجيب حاجه
تعقل التربيه
اي مسلسل اي فيلم يتعدى على هيئه
ممثلين ما شاء الله عليهم اوكي موضوع حساس
اما مش في رمضان هو صحيح اللي يحكيو فيه
مانع وكل صاير كله صاير في تونس بالعكس
انا
يوصل الواقع وصل
المخبي
امتلات بردود الفعل ما بين من يعتبر
المحتوى خارج عن المالوف ويضرب بمضوميه
الاخلاق للمجتمع وما بين مؤيد يراه انتاج
قريب من الواقع ويعكس الصور الحقيقيه
للمجتمع دون تزييف ولا يشكل اي خطر على
الشباب الناشئ
[موسيقى]
اكل
ته
[موسيقى]
وبقي في الختام ان نذكر بابرز العناوين
السفاره في اسرائيل شرطه تتاهب وفوضى تهدد
الامن ولجنه الدستور تصادق على التعديلات
القضائيه
هو قاده الاحتجاج يتم السكون بالغائها
[موسيقى]
والاضرابات تهدد بشل اسرائيل بعد الجامعات
نقابه الاطباء تعلن اضرابا شاملا في
النظام الصحي
على وقع التحذيرات الاوروبيه بعد نشر
الاسلحه النوويه موسكو لا تستبعد اي
خيارات للرد عن العقوبات الغربيه
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]